[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story claim and counterclaim
over the fate of bakmut President
zolenski denies Putin's assertion that
Russia has now won the lengthy battle
for the Ukrainian City
the war in Ukraine brings the G7
together but President Biden says the
supply of American-made fighter jets
comes on one condition they will not use
it to go on and move into Russian
Geographic territory
pressure builds on Suella brathaman in a
raw over speeding Rishi sunak will
discuss claims that she may have
breached the ministerial code with his
ethics advisor
artificial intelligence calls for
greater regulation within the industry
amid fears AI could become too
unpredictable and dangerous
a Saudi astronauts on the verge of
making history as the first Arab woman
to travel to the International Space
Station
foreign
Manchester City get their hands on the
Premier League trophy after being
crowned champions for the third year in
a row
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's in our
press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
a very good evening thanks for joining
us for over nine months a bloody battle
has raged in the Ukrainian city of
bakmut today with little left but Rubble
President Putin claimed it's now under
Russian control thanks to the help of
mercenaries known as the Wagner group
but Ukraine's president remained defiant
denying the fight is over well Batman
lies on the front line between Russian
and Ukrainian forces in the east of
Ukraine even if Russia has won full
control its Victory would be largely
symbolic as Mr zelenski conceded today
it has already been almost entirely
destroyed our International
correspondent Alex Rossi reports now
from Eastern Ukraine
[Music]
the picture could not be clearer Wagner
forces waving flags triumphantly atop of
devastated buildings in back Moots
leader of the mercenary group yevgeni
pragoshin seen here congratulating his
men outside the train station in the
center claims Russian forces have now
captured the entire city
there was an inevitability about this
moment
we visited Ukrainian defensive positions
near the city a few days ago and the
Defenders hold appeared to be slipping
in the face of advancing Russian forces
a few kilometers from Batman at the
moment
there's quite a lot of incoming shells
which we're hearing crashing around this
position at the moment but this is what
it's like night and day the soldiers say
it's just constant
this battle has gone on for months we
last got inside back moot at the end of
January
every building was damaged by the
fighting the city has seen the fiercest
Urban combat since World War II
in Japan for the G7 Vladimir zelenski
who was meeting with the U.S president
acknowledged the situation was desperate
but later maintained Ukraine would keep
up its defense
you have to to understand that there is
nothing they destroyed everything there
are no buildings it's a Pity it's
tragedy but for for today
is only in our hearts
but the horrific battle for back moves
will not decide the outcome of this
conflict it is of limited strategic
value
what's happened here is though a blow
for Ukraine it's invested huge amounts
of resource in its defense
Russia's Declaration of Victory comes
though at an enormous cost Moscow has
won a place of ruination tens of
thousands of Russian soldiers have been
killed here and there's nothing left in
the city it is absolutely devastated
Alex Rossi Sky News eastern Ukraine
well on the final day of the G7 Summit
in Hiroshima leaders of the world's
richest democracies said they wouldn't
back down from supporting Ukraine Joe
Biden said he'd received assurances from
president zielinski that F-16 fighter
jets provided by the West would not be
used against Russian territory other
leaders took the opportunity to remind
Their audience that it's not just Russia
but China too which remains a threat to
the West here's our International
Affairs editor Dominic wacol
it's a place that symbolizes like no
other the horrors of War but also the
promise of renewal
Vladimir zielinski came to pay his
respects at Hiroshima and he said to
find Hope
sure
the pictures of ruined Hiroshima
really remind me totally remind me
and other similar settlements and towns
just the same nothing alive left all of
the buildings have been ruined
and now Hiroshima is a rebuilt City
president zielinski has spent the week
on a whirlwind tour maximizing
diplomatic support before Ukraine's
counter-offensive can begin he is now
sounding increasingly confident and
uncompromising in his demands of the
enemy
if Russia is allowed to keep even a
sliver of the territory it occupies
international law will never again apply
but the biggest news this weekend f-16s
will be sent finally to Ukraine
American-made modern fighter jets could
make all the difference in this war when
they'll be sent isn't clear and they'll
be supplied with conditions attached
says Joe Biden I have a flat Assurance
from the from zielinski that they will
not they will not use it to go on and
move into Russian Geographic territory
but wherever Russian troops are within
Ukraine and the area they would be able
to do that when it was once G7 plus
Russia Ukraine is now the honored guest
pictures that will pack a punch in
Moscow but Beijing too Russia's failure
so far in this war a clear deterrence to
China not to invade Taiwan thank you
Britain's prime minister echoing the
sentiments of his G7 allies China poses
the biggest challenge of our age to
Global Security and prosperity
they are increasingly authoritarian at
home and assertive abroad
and as the G7 have showed the UK's
response is completely aligned with our
allies
this is all about de-risking not
decoupling
and with the G7 we are taking steps to
prevent China from using economic
coercion to interfere in The Sovereign
Affairs of others
president zielinski's Whistle Stop
diplomacy has paid dividends heading
home now with fresh assurances from
allies his military is counter-offensive
must surely now be imminent Dominic
wagorn Sky News
well once Rishi sunak arrives back he'll
consult his independent ethics advisor
about claims the Home Secretary broke
the ministerial code swella bravamoni is
reported to have asked civil servants
and advisers to arrange a one-on-one
speed awareness course in an attempt to
avoid attending a group course or
getting three points on her license a
political correspondent Rob power
reports
the Home Secretary this afternoon events
at the wheel now causing her grief
was caught speeding last summer and
according to the Sunday Times asked
civil servants and an advisor to try and
arrange a private speed awareness course
instead of attending a regular group
session when this was refused she
instead took the points and paid a fine
the Prime Minister unaware of the
penalty until this weekend seeming
frustrated to be asked about it did you
have any questions about the summit I'm
ducking the question of whether he had
full confidence in his Home Secretary I
don't know the full details of what has
happened nor have I spoken to the Home
Secretary I think you can see firsthand
what I've been doing over the last day
or so but I understand that she's
expressed regret for speeding accepted
the penalty and paid the fine number 10
later said the Prime Minister did have
confidence in Sue Ella bravaman labor
calling for an inquiry into whether the
ministerial code had been breached
Zoella brotherman's got got form on this
hasn't she you'll remember she actually
had to resign as home secretary under
Liz truss because she sent confidential
documents to atori MP when she shouldn't
have done that and Rishi sunak
reappointed her others say high-profile
people like the Home Secretary are
allowed to take private speeding courses
she is eligible for a one-to-one and
many of the course providers actually
prefer to have a one-to-one because it
proves to be less of a distraction
so from that perspective she's done
absolutely nothing wrong
but critics say asking civil servants at
the home office to deal with personal
affairs would be against the rules while
some suggest Suella bravman was trying
to avoid being publicly identified by
attempting to arrange a private course
those close to her site security issues
and say her Protection Team would have
needed to come to any group session this
comes at a tense time for the Home
Secretary who's no stranger to
controversy
in her Hampshire seat today little
sympathy from voters if I did it or
anybody else did it and we were
fine or whatever
I don't think the
Audi party wants to see her go and she
has her their full support
on the boat
a polarizing figure Suella bravman
frustrated some party colleagues this
week with a Punchy and personal speech
at a right-wing conference
Under Pressure over migration too it all
makes for a tense political backdrop
from which embarrassing stories often
more easily emerge
well let's bring in Rob who's outside
the home office in Westminster for us
tonight so Rob how significant is this
meeting between the Prime Minister and
his ethics advisor
well it's significant because that may
well be the point where a decisions made
about whether there's a formal
investigation into whether Sue Ella
Braven broke the ministerial code that's
what labor has been calling for also
tomorrow though suela bravman will be in
the Commons facing questions from MPS as
part of the regular session of home
office questions in terms of where she
goes next I don't think in isolation the
speeding situation will spell the end of
her career here at the home office but I
think the danger for the Home Secretary
lies in the fact that it's another
factor in the increasingly fraughtened
busy political landscape she is trying
to navigate later this week we'll get
new data about legal net migration it's
likely to show it hitting another record
high you know Zoella Braven has been
pushing forward some measures to try and
curb that and while some of those May
well be announced in the coming days
some of the more stringent options have
run into a degree of resistance in the
cabinet with people like the chancellor
and the education secretary then there's
that speech she gave almost a week ago
just up the road from here that didn't
go down well with some colleagues in her
party who felt that it sounded almost
more like something a Tory leadership
Contender would give rather than a
sitting government Minister then there's
a Row brewing tonight over whether one
of her advisory team misled journalists
over whether she had got a speeding
penalty in the first place so the Home
Secretary is creating a lot of noise and
the risk is is that that noise can
spiral as one controversy feeds another
annoying more people and frustrating
more people around her in the process so
she's not in a comfortable position the
home office is known as something of a
graveyard for ministers and it could yet
claim another scalp okay Rob outside the
home office thank you
to Greece now the current prime
minister's conservative party has
claimed victory in the country's
parliamentary election kiriakos
mitzutakis says the win gives him a
decisive mandate but for newly
introduced electoral system of
proportional representation means it's
unlikely he'll secure enough seats to
form a government without the need to
seek Coalition Partners he'll have three
days to negotiate a coalition with other
parties but if that fails a second
election could be held next month
Italy's Prime Minister has visited areas
in the north of the country where floods
have killed 14 people and caused
extensive damage Georgie Maloney
returned early from the G7 Summit to
lead the emergency response to the
flooding which has forced 36 000 people
from their homes a red alert remains in
place tonight for flooding along with
the danger of further landslides
at least 12 people have been killed and
more than 100 injured after a stampede
during a football match in El Salvador
the crash happened when fans pushed
through one of the gates at the
cascatlin stadium forcing officials to
suspend the quarter-final match 16
minutes into the game to allow those
hurt to be treated on the pitch
an astronaut from Saudi Arabia is on the
verge of making history as the first
Arab woman to travel to the
International Space Station Rana banawi
will represent the Saudi Arabian
government on a private Mission led by
space company Axiom space it's set off
it's set to take off tonight liftoff
scheduled at NASA's Kennedy Space Center
there in Florida in around 20 minutes or
so
worked for the past 10 years as a
researcher so research has been my
passion in life I have worked on stem
cells and tissue re-engineering and I'm
very happy and honored to be here today
representing the government of Saudi
Arabia and the study space commission as
the the first Saudi women astronaut
going to the International Space Station
now we'll be showing that for you live
weather permitting of course Manchester
City have lifted the Premier League
trophy for the third consecutive season
their status as Champions was confirmed
yesterday after closest challenges
Arsenal lost to Nottingham Forest but
the players and their fans had to wait
until the conclusion of today's game
against Chelsea which city won one nil
to get their hands on the trophy our
north of England correspondent Katarina
vitotsi was there
[Applause]
seems familiar
this is Manchester City's third
consecutive premier league title for an
incredible fifth time in six years oh
it's special and I'm just gonna enjoy
this day this is a so special moment
with this Trophy and with all the
all the players and the whole whole club
without the club would not be possible
and teammates and everything so it's
amazing
[Applause]
the team arrived at today's Chelsea
Clash already Champions
[Applause]
After Arsenal's loss on Saturday gave
City an unassailable lead I'd love to
have won it today and win the league but
you know the Champions champions again
three times well done because they've
done amazing already yeah so we can go
all the way through the bits absolutely
yeah so we could enjoy it today really
this was on many backs Norwegian Striker
erling Harland in his first year at City
broke the Premier League record for most
goals in a season my daughter and I said
he would smash all the records if he
came here and he has and he's you know
incredible absolutely amazing love it
hence the Hat
[Music]
what a day this has been for fans their
team Premier League champions for the
third consecutive time but the eyes on
the prize here are focus
[Music]
with that and the FA Cup final two
There's real belief here that City can
achieve the treble
but hanging over celebrations are
ongoing questions about whether the club
has broken premier league rules on
spending
Manchester City
face more than 100 charges from the
Premier League
um
and this is breaching of financial rules
in relation to uh inflating how much
they've been receiving and
trying to say they've spent less than
what they have because it's complicated
because they haven't won these titles
just because of the money they've spent
but clearly it gives you a huge
advantage
City denies any wrongdoing and today was
less about charges more about trophies
and this the latest addition to the
team's growing collection
Sky News at Manchester
the boss of a British artificial
intelligence company is told Sky News he
fears his industry could become too
unpredictable and potentially dangerous
unless more is done to control it Emmett
mustache says some Labs fear without
changes AI technology could pose an
existential threat to humanity this
report from our Science and Technology
editor Tom Clark
the more you look the more AI there is
out there
london-based Synthesia are a leader in
using machine intelligence to turn text
into video we make video production easy
for our clients I sat down with Daniel
only it's not him speaking including
one-third of the Fortune 100 but his
Avatar so all that had to happen is me
speaking into camera for two three
minutes and then we were able to train
our AEI models let's get started their
clients are businesses wanting to create
and revise realistic video presentations
in any language but they're Keen to
stress they're not creating deep fakes
there is much more under the hood of
these given that we only create
someone's likeness with their explicit
consent you can't just generate video of
anyone We Believe That explicit consent
content moderation and really working
with the wider Community are the keys to
an ethical platform
but the proliferation of other AIS
trained on any data you want in some
cases the entire internet threatens to
pollute the online world with a tidal
wave of misinformation harmful content
or just rubbish if you look at coding
fifty percent of all the code generated
now is AI generated can we set standards
around what we feed them so we don't
feed them junk food we feed them better
quality inputs so they have better
quality outputs more Stack's company has
just launched its latest text to image
AI deep Floyd if you can imagine it it
can make a picture of it raising
questions about copyright and Truth can
we get it to generate a bit of a fake
news story a UFO
looming down over the houses of
Parliament in London
okay wow the problem is even using some
classic tools like Photoshop people can
do a lot of fakes nowadays I think maybe
in the next few years we will see a lot
of fake images that will be very very
close to real quality clearly these
images are watermarked to show their AI
generated but it doesn't take much
expertise to get around that and no one
quite knows how to spot AI generated
text this happened with social media you
know maybe a decade ago is that the
technology moves so fast and the Bad
actors can explode it quicker than uh
protections can be put in place we
remain really concerned about
uh just an average internet user's
ability to find accurate information and
know that that is the accurate
information
whether their products are
self-contained business tools or
publicly available content generating
machines AI Pioneers say regulation is
needed but while we wait to see what
that looks like the technology race is
ever onwards Tom Clark Sky News
plans have been unveiled by the
government to remove what it calls
unnecessary red tape impacting British
wine producers and importers the
environment secretary trees coffee
claims brexit has provided the
opportunity to help British Vineyards
Thrive Butters Laura bundock explains
that some producers and Traders think
the new rules could in fact lead to the
British brand being tarnished
Jan makowski's been growing grapes for
10 years his Oxfordshire Vines are
thriving but he's worried changes to the
rules will cause producers problems I
think it could turn out to be a
double-edged sword yes my advice to any
politician would be be careful what you
wish for if you liberalize the market
and throw away the rules without
introducing other safeguards then uh
there are always going to be
unscrupulous players who will knock out
some cheap plonk at the bottom end and
that that could tarnish our image much
of the UK's wine industry is regulated
by EU rules the government wants to lose
these laws and says this could boost
business by 118 million pounds at the
moment things like wine they're governed
by 400 pages of regulations we think a
lot of that can be stripped away and
make sure that frankly this should
produce uh potentially up to 50 pence
off the cost of a bottle of wine
The Producers like Yan say prices won't
change for high-end English wines there
is a really important difference between
English wines and British wines English
wines use grapes grown here and the wine
has to be made here whereas British
wines can use grapes from anywhere
around the world they're the wines that
are set to benefit from these changes
changes which would come under the
controversial retained EU law Bill
legislation to determine which EU laws
are replaced or kept but some say there
are bigger issues to address than wine
industry rules it's not an uncoinc
Dental that we're the government's
having walked back their plans on the
retained EU law Bill to scrap all of
this EU law is finding some areas where
it feels it can present improvements and
certainly um uh what the changes around
wine look pretty small compared to what
was originally proposed to drop all EU
laws English wines now have a global
reputation producers say brexits made
life harder creating labor shortages and
complicating exports but the industry is
still growing
with or without EU rules Laura bundock
Sky News
okay time for the sport now with Allison
this Sky News sports bulletin is brought
to you by Vitality getting more people
more active live life with vitality
thank you
foreign
[Music]
during the year where I can really
simplify and break down what it means to
be a Muslim for me it's also a month of
discipline riding out having a routine
takes discipline so we come in and
get the horses cleaned and tacked up
grab your equipment get on can you
explain what Siri is
um it's a meal just before Fajr which is
just Before Sunrise
encouraged us to eat a small meal
so we can keep going through the day
whilst we're fasting it's a very blessed
meal so I try when I can and when I'm
not too tired to eat this morning I had
porridge and a leftover sandwich
in terms of riding out it's not too hard
I only have two horses a day in the
mornings
um when I'm writing more it's a sort of
three four horses a day it can get quite
tough
um but
currently I've just stuck to two so
we're all good so far can be quite tough
it is a lot of patience but once you get
a routine of just eating slightly later
and having breakfast so early you just
sort of like your body adjusts to it
also reminds you that like
you know we are simple creatures human
beings and you know we're not as
Invincible as we think and I think in
the 21st century we forget how fragile
as humans we are and how much we depend
on things
um and for me specifically like in a
world where everything is so easy to get
having you know having restrictions and
practicing like restricting your desires
is is all about sort of like
self-discipline and understanding your
limits this is a day in the life of me
training in the mornings
um I'm gonna head back to my house to
pray
and during Ramadan my goal is to try and
pray my prayers on time so I've gotta
head back quite quickly
[Music]
so after my training I always try and
grab a shower and prepare for my second
prayer of the day with the hood before I
can do that I have to do a lot which is
a cleansing process how often do you
read the Quran during Ramadan it is one
of the main things that we're supposed
to focus on is returning back to the
Quran and getting closer to the Quran so
I'm gonna make a huge effort to try and
read this more often
now it's time to free acid
so the sun setting which means that I
need to go and pray my fourth prayer of
the day I'm going to make my world this
guy new sports bulletin is brought to
you by vitality
Alison thank you and that was Sky News
at 10 coming up we're going to take a
first look at Monday's front pages in
The Press preview including this story
it's on the front of tomorrow's Guardian
their headline pressure on prime
minister to launch inquiry into
bravaman's speeding we're out on his way
back from Japan of course and tonight
I'll be joined by the former
conservative special advisor Anita bote
and a political editor of the HuffPost
UK Kevin Schofield do join us all next
[Music]